i had like the easiest time in the
jungle of anyone on this film channing
and sandra like hato and the rest of the
crew worked very hard in the jungle i
came you know i had a i was sweaty
because i'm fully suited for the whole
thing but it was it was great how great
does it feel to be here at south by
southwest really kicking off the
festivities with your film it's really
nice it's uh you know it's the first
time
i've done anything like this in two
years uh this will be the first time
i've sat in a cinema to see a movie in
two years um so yeah i'm really it's a
little bit weird that that is a film
that i'm in but it's you know yeah it's
nice and as a villain what made you want
to be a part of this project as the bad
guy if you got a script where they were
like do you want to be the villain to
sandra bullock and channing tatum's
heroes you'd be like yeah of course um
so it was it was a very late i knew they
were involved i love both of them i
and then i love the script like the
script's really really funny and just um
adam and aaron did an amazing job on
making it and yeah it was a very easy
choice
miss sage i enjoyed your book about the
lost city and i believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your seatbelt
you know everyone keeps talking about
the chemistry that channing and sandra
have okay you were on set you know what
it was like what what is it about those
two um i think they are i think
chemistry mostly comes down to like
openness and being curious and open
about the other person that you're
working with and both channing and
sandra are that and they also just like
they are they would both be i think very
hard people to not have chemistry with
like they're both incredibly like nice
and fun i mean channing can start a
party on his own in a room so like and i
think you know i feel like it was it was
very easy for them to find that and the
perfect pair to uh you know take leeches
off of channing's naked body right
absolutely i was not there for that
scene on that day but i have heard a lot
about it and i believe that was
channing's first day on the film where
he just had to get naked second second
down the film and getting naked in front
of the crew a traditional actor's
greeting so tonight when you watch the
film are you kind of like ah close the
eyes oh wait where the naked sing no
god we should all be so lucky to look at
channing tatum's naked body um yeah no i
uh i'm not i'm not gonna be squirming to
that but i'm looking forward that's i
think there are so many scenes i'm not
in that i wasn't there for that i'm
really looking forward to like seeing
them yeah you know your coaster sandra
has a restaurant here in austin are you
guys all celebrating together i think we
will we're this is the start of a long
press tour so i think we will have many
meals and hopefully many celebrations
and things um but yeah no it's hopefully
we'll have a good night tonight
[Music]
you